let's ask the tough questions today how
many bodies does it take for a woman to
become a hoe
yeah
I want to start with the men and then
the woman can answer how many bodies
yeah how many bodies does it take as in
like uh high level men or oh bodies I
thought you said Bodies Okay
um
in my experience
Sun changes after like
three people I know
oh
if you slept with three people that
you've actually yeah
so I don't know I don't I don't have an
opinion for you know women before that
but when I meet someone or like you know
they come into the same scene as me Etc
if she's been with
more than
to put more than two people but
definitely three then that's like
because so you're saying like you're
never gonna know the actual body count
so you kind of Base it by the number of
dudes that you know that she's slept
with yeah so if you find out about three
then she's a hoe it's how you conduct
yourself yeah
in the room if I know two of you guys in
the general scene in London that you've
been with then it's um because it's too
much of a small walk so you've been
about no I'm about but no the girl the
girl if the girls had three men that you
know that means she's been about to go
all the way to the three that you know
in your life The Coincidence also my
boys are some of the top guys in it so
if if you've been with one of my boys
then I know
what about you
[ __ ] his wife's got one so is it two
you know what I'll be a little bit more
generous on that front maybe I'll say
when you hit the double double figures
so ten yeah okay what about you
uh I'll maybe say when you roughly hit
above maybe over seven but then then
again some girls
be dating a lot but they're not really
hurting but they'll be dating and
hopeless Romantics will fall in love and
you know what I'm saying and then
that'll add up so as he said like yeah
when it starts reaching 9 10 then it's
like yeah you just
you hate reaching the whole face so okay
so 9 10 what about you
so mine is kind of like age condition
okay so if you're like in your 20s and
you're over 10 yeah you're done if you
hit 30 and you're over 15. okay speak so
15 by 30 10 before okay ladies what do
you guys think how many bodies does it
take for a girl to become a hoe
um yeah I'll agree with you I think it's
like very age conditioned but I do think
like
I don't know because I know some people
like I think it's like a double digits
yeah that's when you like become a high
I think a hoe can reform
um
but then like oh this is kind of
embarrassing to admit but like I'm only
19. my I've never [ __ ] before like
I've still never been [ __ ] I'm still a
virgin I don't think it's embarrassing
obviously I've obviously done like stuff
we've got as nine guys to like count
um but people would still call me at
home because I like post provocative or
like I think it's just very subjective
on what you think our hoe is like I have
people call me a hoe every day because I
like post half naked but I've actually
never been [ __ ] before and like all my
hoe in is like I've done like online
stuff and whatever but yeah there's
levels the whole window so that's why I
will say there's there's levels you know
you can get an escort that's gonna
everything you can get escort that's
going to talk to you on the phone like
there's levels I mean one level is
language right so
if you refer to yourself as like being
[ __ ]
I'm very I'm very like confused or like
made lava yeah you want to use one of
the nice words you know
that's the whole language right there
I'm just really direct sorry
um uh what about uh you two haven't
answered yet
um I'm kind of like where I've forgotten
your name Alex Alex says
um like if I don't know then like who am
I to call you a hoe you know and
like I would probably say double digits
maybe but then I know friends that are
in double digits and I'm like I love
them so it's like as hoes or as people
it's humans
they could be a nice hole
but why would I call it but for me
but for me to use that language towards
somebody for me in that moment like I
can't say that I love somebody and call
them a hoe like it doesn't come in the
same sentence so like to me you're just
experienced life to its fullest right
yeah I can't I can't call you a hoe and
then say I love you like they don't come
in the same sentence I wouldn't call
someone a hopeful stuff
together
to be fair like I have a very different
definition of a hoe because I I think of
a whole someone who's who who sleeps
around carelessly yeah consciously oh
yeah yeah I think I think someone who
sleeps in unconsciously whether they've
slept with 10 you know 20 people
whatever I mean after after a point it's
like it's hard to consciously sleep with
like 40 people but you know that that's
that's how I think of it so close to me
have an energy it's a spiritual Vibe
it's like that's Tendencies
well in Tantra they exchange energy on
so many different levels with people and
it's not classed as being a hoe like you
are there's no penetration energy but
for some people if you're touching so
like I'm a tantric practitioner and we
like we get taught how to do certain
things to people and it's not about and
you can give that service but would you
then class me as a horror like I don't
do that by the way but I mean for some
tantric practitioners but it's not
called our a prostitute or a horror
because I mean it's very very very
conscious and it's a massive exchange of
energy that can be you can manifest you
can do something for women
I mean men I'll sleep with goddamn
anything anyhow
why don't you do those services that you
just said that you
um
no I don't feel that I'm at a space
where I
I give that to somebody because for me I
would I need to be really trusting of
somebody to get to that point of
intimacy to that level because I as much
as I'm very out there with my thoughts
and opinions me exchanging energy with
you I understand the level of energy
that I am able to give and so I can't
just touch somebody I know how to do it
but I yeah you just don't I just don't
choose to yeah I was gonna say then it
means that in in a way because it's
conscious you exactly you knowingly
don't want to be exchanging energy with
so many people yeah so in a way it will
take a certain type of person to do you
take a hole to do that [ __ ] exactly what
I was getting at my brother you got it
all right I got you bro how many how
many bodies is Too Many Bodies too
but what the hell how many I think
a friends
but you can tell my friends that at home
if they've slept over 15 people I'll be
like you at home but I love you [ __ ]
okay 15. yeah I think if I feel like if
you're uh my age 25 and you've slept
over 15 then it's like
yeah
you must have gone gone through a dark
path something must have happened yeah
you've been streaming
and back to what you were saying I do
think people nowadays don't think sex is
like a big deal like it is a big deal
like for me to especially for a woman
like for me to let someone inside of me
that is literally so personal that is so
like that should only be shared with
someone I genuinely really care about
you guys can come out and wash their
dick in there please like actually
letting someone inside this is the same
as like you're becoming a part of me
basically yeah for that period of time
period of Time Forever DNA yes when a
man goes inside of you then your soul
connected DNA is inside you for life
you're you're connected to that person
on a soul level it's not just oh yeah I
can you can do lots of rituals but at
the same time that's why girls that do
sleep around you can bear
what do you what do you mean their DNA
is that well when somebody comes inside
you to be graphic like that's okay just
use condoms then
yeah I get that but I mean at the same
time not everybody is using condoms
that's why there's so many questions
someone's body is actually entering
yours no I'm just saying in terms of the
DNA thing for the rest of your life on
an energetic level on an energetic level
wrap it up still exchanging energy with
somebody so it's like yeah you can wrap
it up but I mean energy isn't just
inside this physical thing yeah just
trotting around uh what about you de
Nava oh it's not really award as in my
vocabulary
therefore
I would say
I'm trying to think of a different way
how is the female version of a simp
where you are eaten and you don't eat
that's it which means that if you're a
woman yeah and you're being used by men
because you are insecure because that's
when you're going to be likely to be
labeled a hoe you know what I'm saying
whereas I believe in sexual Freedom
which means that you shouldn't be
labeled anything for wanting to be with
a man I have my name you see me because
I don't have a husband I'm gonna have
sex please give me a number
it depends it depends it depends like
for example I know women that's that
with five men they'll be like actually
do you know what you're kind of loose
but then I know that people that slept
with five men that actually I'm like you
know what I understand why you do this
okay
all right five a hoe or not a hoe yes
please yes it depends on the person okay
okay 50. you sound like my teacher
please
I think she's maybe damaged okay
okay let's use the word damaged and
everyone else this means hell yeah
damage damaged is she damaged at 10.
depends on high intentions okay so maybe
uh maybe not 15 is she damaged depends
on her intentions okay when does it
switch to yes
so when she's letting men go 20 is she
damaged
yeah depends on her intentions okay 30
is she damaged
I just want to know when it switches out
um let's say 30 by 30. under what
conditions how many were boyfriends
okay you know what for [ __ ] to give
girls let's say half were boyfriends
then nah what if she was having
threesomes with her boyfriend how does
that change because if you haven't if
you're in a relationship for a long long
time maybe you want to open that stuff
I think anyone that does an open
relationship that like that's hopeless
I believe in sexual Liberation it
doesn't mean that you need to be labeled
all it means is how you feel about the
action that you're doing so I don't like
it when I don't think there's anything
liberating for sex with women there is a
woman a woman has needs you really think
that woman doesn't want the most yeah
but you can get your needs met by a
boyfriend or a husband yeah and that's
what I'm saying so sex is not really
what you should look on your body how is
it liberating to sleep around and not
call someone a hug no it is liberating
to be able to choose to have sex when
have we ever not been able to choose
listener and that's what I'm saying
no there's a difference though no
because this is the thing as a woman if
you are not able to make a choice yeah
based on who you are and what you want
then you are more likely to be damaged
because your decision making is cute if
you don't want to be having sex with men
but you you're using sex as a way to
validate your beauty to validate that
you are somebody that is desirable then
that is damage and a lot of women in
that situation some girls I think they
just enjoy sex literally some girls got
crazy sex drive so I'm done some of them
but why can't you do that with one
person that knows exactly in and out
what you like because problem is finding
the person that's compatible you're
lucky that you found somebody that's so
young and you're working as a woman I'm
gonna agree with on a level and say like
what what is this is why I don't care
about this space what is the obsession
with like judging other people's sexual
partners and like what they do I don't
understand how grown man will sit down
and be like because we have children
with this many people yeah let me tell
you let me ask you a question because we
have children to raise and if I have
five girls I do not want somebody who is
sexually liberated to teach my young
female children to grow up in a world
that they feel like they can just go
around and sleep around
and ain't gonna have no repercussions
now no one's saying that you can't go
out and sleep with whoever you want to
no one's saying that but what we're
saying is that comes with repercussions
and consequences and the consequences
are if you're looking for a husband
you're going to be deemed less valuable
but I think so to some guys what were
you gonna say so forget what I was going
to say I just want to respond to what he
says I think um when you um when the
problem is that now social media are the
women people that have been sexually
liberated or whatever you want to call
it
um they say you know just do what you
want to be do just be free and I think I
mean as a woman I can't judge other
women like dude your thing it doesn't
affect me right it's not that I'm gonna
marry you but I think um the one thing
that lacks in our society right now is
the fact that there is no education for
consequences of what actually happens if
you sleep with 20 50 because I know
girls personally and I don't know three
four five ten girls I know multiple
girls that at my age have body counts of
over a hundred over 100.
what's the consequences from that
because you can catch an STD sleeping
with one person and you can catch an STD
sleeping 100.
my question is is what is the
consequence that you can't parabon for
example yeah it's mental you lose it why
don't you start comparing every man that
you slept with and no one is Ever Enough
yeah because you may find someone for
example our relationship someone might
look at it it's not perfect whatever but
for me it's perfect I can easily say
that it's personalized I mean you're
both like fitness models so I think
you're too different but but
next season like literally besides each
other yeah so the way I started and the
way that you started was literally yeah
growing up no no I'm not I'm not in fact
you said no no it's not a boxer but he's
I've been in the fitness team yeah but
what I was saying is like there's always
going to be something right the fact
that he freaking drops his towel on the
floor when he comes out the bathtub that
pisses me the [ __ ] off
[Laughter]
you literally like takes over the whole
bed the fact that you know there's
certain things you're always going to
not like about a person there's always
little you know icks but nowadays
woman's list of icks are ridiculous and
then you look at your partner now you're
with at the moment and I and I see that
through some of my friends and they'll
say oh he's missing this and yeah and
then they'll see that in someone they
may be working with or they meet in a
club or whatever and all of a sudden
it's like oh he fulfills that 20 or that
10 and all of a sudden they're missing
out and then they go into that
relationship and they find out actually
but then they went into that one and
it's that one's missing it and they mess
up a good thing because they're looking
for the one thing that that guy didn't
have instead of just working with what
they got basically yeah as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible